HOPE AMERICANS SEE HIS VISION AS
WELL.
>> NOW, YOUR HUSBAND IS 80 YEARS
OLD.
>> MM-HMM.
>> IF HE WINS A SECOND TERM, HE
WOULD BE 82 AT INAUGURATION.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO SAY MAYBE HE'S TOO OLD TO BE
PRESIDENT?
ARE THOSE FAIR QUESTIONS AND
CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAVING?
>> I SAY LOOK AT WHAT HE'S DONE.
YOU KNOW, LOOK AT WHAT HE'S
DOING.
LOOK AT HOW PHYSICALLY HE'S GOT
THE GOOD BILL OF HEALTH FROM THE
DOCTORS TO HIS PHYSICALS.
BUT HOW MANY 30-YEAR-OLDS COULD
TRAVEL TO POLAND, GET ON THE
TRAIN, GO NINE MORE HOURS, GO TO
UKRAINE, MEET WITH PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY?
HIS ENERGY LEVEL, HIS LEVEL OF
PASSION, SO LOOK AT THE MAN.
LOOK WHAT HE'S DOING.
LOOK WHAT HE CONTINUES TO DO
EACH AND EVERY DAY, AND MAKE
YOUR DECISION.
IT'S UP TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> NIKKI HALEY, ONE OF THE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES IS CALLING
FOR MENTAL COMPETENCY TESTS FOR
THOSE POLITICIANS OVER THE AGE
OF 75.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> WOULD YOUR HUSBAND EVER TAKE
ONE OF THOSE?
>> I MEAN, WE HAVEN'T EVEN
DISCUSSED -- WE WOULD NEVER EVEN
DISCUSS SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> YOU TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOUR HUSBAND TRAVELING TO
UKRAINE AND POLAND THIS PAST
WEEK.
YOU ALSO HAVE TOLD US THAT YOU
FOUND OUT KIND OF LAST MINUTE
THAT HE WAS GOING TO BE MAKING
THIS SECRET TRIP --
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY.
>> -- TO UKRAINE.
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT WAS IT LIKE FOR THOSE
TEN HOURS WHEN HE WAS TAKING
THAT TRAIN RIDE INTO UKRAINE AND
NO ONE KNEW.
HOW WORRIED WERE YOU IN THOSE
MOMENTS?
>> I WAS OF COURSE WORRIED, I
WAS REALLY WORRIED.
BUT YOU KNOW, ONE THING -- AND I
HAVE TO SAY THIS WITH ALL MY
HEART -- ONE THING THAT I TRULY
BELIEVE IN IS THE STRENGTH OF
OUR MILITARY AND HOW EVERYTHING
WAS SO PLANNED OUT AND THE
SECRET SERVICE AND WHAT AN
AMAZING JOB THEY DID IN PULLING
OFF THE TRIP AND KEEPING MY
HUSBAND SAFE.
I MEAN, I'M WATCHING THE TV THIS
MORNING AND I'M SEEING -- IT'S
JUST INCREDIBLE WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THE AIR AND IN THE SEA, AND I
HOPE THAT AMERICANS REALLY TAKE
NOTE OF IT.
LIKE WE HAVE TO GIVE THE
SUPPORT, ALL OF OUR SUPPORT TO
OUR MILITARY BECAUSE OF WHAT A
GREAT JOB THEY DO, AND THE
SECRET SERVICE IS RIGHT THERE
HAND IN HAND.
>> WERE YOU ABLE TO KEEP TABS ON
HIM --
>> OH, YEAH.
>> WHEN HE WAS -- DID HE
COMMUNICATE?
>> THROUGH TEXT.
>> WAS HE TEXTING YOU ON THE
TRAIN?
>> WELL, HE WAS -- NO, HE WASN'T
TEXTING ME ON THE TRAIN, BUT YOU
KNOW, IT WAS IN THE BACK OF MY
MIND, AND SO I MEAN, I WAS KIND
OF AWARE THAT HE WAS, YOU KNOW,
SAFE AND I JUST SAID A LOT OF
PRAYERS.
>> DID HE GIVE YOU A CALL WHEN
HE MADE IT BACK INTO POLAND?
>> OH, YES.
>> AND WHAT WAS HIS REFLECTION
ON THIS TRIP?
>> WE DIDN'T REALLY TALK ABOUT
IT.
I THINK IT WILL BE JUST BETTER
TO TALK ABOUT IT IN PRIVATE, YOU
KNOW.
>> YEAH, HAVE YOU HAD THE CHANCE
TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT THIS TRIP
YET?
>> OH, YEAH, WE'VE SPOKEN A
COUPLE OF TIMES, AND FACE TIMED
AND SO, YEAH, AND HE LOOKS
GREAT.
I MEAN, SO HE DOESN'T LOOK TIRED
OR, YEAH.
>> HOW OFTEN DO YOU GUYS FACE
TIME?
>> I DON'T KNOW, A COUPLE TIMES
A DAY.
>> EVEN IF YOU'RE JUST IN D.C.
OR WHEN YOU'RE TRAVELING?
>> I'M TRAVELING, I'M AT WORK.
I MEAN, HE CALLS -- HE CALLS A
LOT.
>> DOES HE CALL YOU MORE OR DO
YOU CALL HIM MORE?
>> I THINK HE CALLS ME MORE.
>> I WANT TO TURN TO ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT HAS COME UP AMONGST
REPUBLICANS A LOT, AND YOUR SON
HUNTER HAS REALLY BEEN A TARGET
FOR REPUBLICANS OVER THE YEARS
AND LIKELY WILL BE IN THE YEARS
TO COME.
HOW DOES YOUR FAMILY DEAL WITH
THAT INTENSE FOCUS ON HUNTER?
>> WE DEAL WITH IT BY JUST I
GUESS HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE.
I LOVE HUNTER AND I'LL SUPPORT
HIM IN ANY WAY I CAN, AND THAT'S
HOW I LOOK AT THINGS.
>> HAS THE WAVE OF
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HIM, DOES
THAT FACTOR INTO ANY OF THE
THINKING HEADING INTO 2024?
>> NO.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
APPOINTED A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
LOOK INTO THE WAY YOUR HUSBAND
HANDLED CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WHEN HE LEFT THE VICE
PRESIDENCIES.
WHEN DID YOU FIRST FIND OUT
ABOUT THESE DOCUMENTS?
WERE YOU SURPRISED?
>> PROBABLY WHEN THE REST OF
AMERICA DID.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED.
WE HAD NO IDEA, AND SO I THINK
WE FOUND OUT WHEN EVERYONE ELSE
DID.
>> WHERE IN THE HOUSE WERE THEY?
WERE THEY IN A SECURE LOCATION?
DID PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THEM?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY WERE AT
THE BIDEN PENN CENTER.
>> AND THERE WERE SOME AT YOUR
HOME IN WILMINGTON.
>> AND I THINK THOSE WERE IN THE
GARAGE, BELIEVE ME, ARLETTE, I
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO THROUGH
THE BOXES IN THE GARAGE.
WE HAD NO IDEA THEY WERE EVEN
DOWN THERE.
>> I WANTED TO TURN BACK TO ONE
CAMPAIGN QUESTION.
YOU AND I --
>> YOU'RE NOT GIVING UP.
>> NO, I'M NOT GIVING UP.
>> YOU'RE SAYING EVERYONE'S
ASKING YOU.
THERE YOU GO.
>> EVERYONE'S ASKING YOU.
DO YOU EVER WORRY ABOUT HOW
GRUELING A CAMPAIGN MIGHT BE ON
HIM?
>> I THINK EVERYONE CAMPAIGN IS
GRUELING.
I DON'T CARE WHETHER YOU'RE 20,
30 OR WHATEVER AGE.
CAMPAIGNS NOW HAVE BECOME REALLY
GRUELING.
AND ARLETTE, YOU KNOW, YOU'VE
BEEN ON A LOT OF CAMPAIGNS.
YOU HAVE TO SEE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN EVEN TEN YEARS AGO AND
TODAY.
>> I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE REALLY
BIG INTO THESE FAMILY MEETINGS.
>> UH-HUH.
>> WAS THERE ONE DEFINITIVE
FAMILY MEETING THAT, OKAY WOORGS
ERE DOING THIS OR HAS THIS BEEN
A ROLLING CONVERSATION?
>> IT'S BEEN ROLLING THIS TIME.
LAST TIME WE DID HAVE A FAMILY
MEETING, AND WE'VE HAD FAMILY
MEETINGS OTHER TIMES, BUT IT'S
SORT OF ROLLING JUST BECAUSE OF
THE PACE OF OUR LIVES, AND SO IF
I CAN GRAB TWO GRANDKIDS HERE
AND SAY, HEY, WHAT ARE YOU
THINKING ABOUT, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS OR, YOU KNOW, OUR
DAUGHTER.
SO I'M SORT OF KEEPING TABS.
>> SO IN YOUR MIND, THIS IS
HAPPENING?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU WANT TO COME?
YOU WANT TO COME ON THE TRAIL?
>> I MIGHT BE COVERING YOU GUYS
ON THE TRAIL AGAIN.
>> OH, GOOD, GOOD.
>> WE ARE BACK NOW WITH ARLETTE.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED LUCKILY BY
AUDI CORNISH AND ABBY PHILLIP.
ARLETTE, I'M GOING TO START WITH
YOU.
SO YOU ASKED ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC HAS BEEN
DISCUSSING ABOUT JOE BIDEN, AND
THEN YOU GET INTO WHAT JILL
BIDEN HAS BEEN UP TO.
WERE YOU SURPRISED BY ANY OF HER
ANSWERS?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT HER
ANSWER REGARDING 2024 IS QUITE
INTERESTING.
I THINK THE WAY THAT SHE
ANSWERED THAT QUESTION REALLY
MAKES IT SEEM AS IF IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF IF BUT WHEN THIS
CAMPAIGN WILL BE LAUNCHED, BUT
SHE ALSO DOES LEAVE AN OPENING
FOR HIM SHOULD HE DECIDE NOT TO
RUN IN 2024.
YOU KNOW, SHE SAYS IT'S JOE'S
DECISION.
THAT THEY'LL SUPPORT HIM IF HE
DOES, BUT THEN SHE SAYS IF HE
DECIDES TO DO SOMETHING ELSE,
WE'LL ALSO SUPPORT HIM THERE.
IT KIND OF PROVIDES YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF ANSWER BOTH WAYS.
THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT I HAD
WITH HER OVER THE COURSE OF
THOSE FIVE DAYS IN AFRICA, IT
REALLY DOES SEEM LIKE THINGS ARE
MOVING TOWARDS HIM RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION AGAIN IN THE COMING
MONTHS.
>> I DO WANT TO ASK ABOUT THIS
CONTROVERSY -- I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S WHAT TO CALL IT -- BUT
OVER AGE, IT'S COME UP AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN, AND NIKKI HALEY PURKD
IT TO A WHOLE 'NOTHER LEVEL WHEN
SHE TALKED ABOUT A COMPETENCY
TEST.
JOE BIDEN -- JILL BIDEN
RESPONDED WITH IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> SHE'S BEEN IN THIS GAME FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FROM
FIRST LADY MICHELLE OBAMA WHO
MARRIED SOMEONE WHO WAS NOT IN
PUBLIC LIFE WHEN THEY FIRST GOT
TOGETHER.
JILL BIDEN'S BEEN IN THIS FOR A
WHILE.
IT ALSO UNDERSCORES THE PROBLEM
FOR THEM.
HERE THEY ARE, SHE'S ON A TRIP
VISITING COUNTRIES IN AFRICA.
THE POSTURE THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS HAD TOWARDS
AFRICA IS RADICALLY DIFFERENT
THAN THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
BUT IT'S A CONVERSATION THAT
CAN'T BE HAD BECAUSE NOT ONLY
ARE PEOPLE FOCUSED ON WHETHER
HE'S GOING TO RUN BUT EVEN
ASKING THE QUESTION SHOULD HE AT
ALL BECAUSE OF HIS AGE.
I MEAN, THAT REALLY GIVES YOU A
SENSE OF THE KIND OF OBSTACLES
FOR THEM.
>> IT ALSO STRUCK ME THAT SHE
WAS ANSWERING THE QUESTION OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AT EVERY CHANCE
SHE GOT, EVEN WHEN ARLETTE
WASN'T ASKING HER ABOUT IT.
>> SHE WAS READY WITH AN ANSWER.
>> SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
UKRAINE TRIP, SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT HIS STAMINA, HIS ABILITY
TO DO ALL OF THAT.
I MEAN, I THINK SHE IS KEENLY
AWARE THAT THIS IS AN
UNAVOIDABLE QUESTION ABOUT HER
HUSBAND, AND SHE IS INJECTING AT
EVERY MOMENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY, THIS IS A GUY WHO CAN KEEP
UP.
THIS IS A GUY WHO HAS WHAT IT
TAKES, WHO'S ALL THERE.
AND YOU KNOW, I MEAN, TO AUDI'S
POINT, JILL BIDEN IS PERHAPS ONE
OF THE MOST PREPARED WOMEN TO
EVER BE FIRST LADY BECAUSE OF
HOW LONG THAT SHE HAS BEEN JOE
BIDEN'S WIFE.
AND I DIDN'T REALLY SEE ANY
DOUBT IN HER IN THIS INTERVIEW.
I THINK SHE THINKS HER HUSBAND
CAN DO IT, AND SHE'S KIND OF
WONDERING WHY WE KEEP ASKING HER
ABOUT IT.
AND THAT REALLY, I THINK, TELLS